Game of Thrones finale you know over 19
million people watch but apparently
there was a large portion of that
audience who hated how the show ended
well now the Starks have a message for
all you haters out there starting with
the queen of the north sophie turner i
love the way this that sonses journey
ended
she never wanted better in French she
never wanted to rule over that many
people would work disrespectful that's
what Sophie is calling the 1.4 million
haters who signed a petition asking for
a season finale redo watching the way
this character finished Game of Thrones
was the most satisfying ending
full disclosure Sofie hasn't actually
seen the final episode since she's been
out doing press promoting her new x-men
film Dark Phoenix this morning mrs. Joe
Jonas posted this fun behind-the-scenes
pic from the set and was quick to point
out the Game of Thrones crew worked
tirelessly over 10 years and 11 months
shooting the last season like
50-something night shoots back we Kit
Harington agrees basically saying the
critics quote can go bleep themselves
love is the death of duty and while
they've been haters coffee cup and water
bottle mistakes we do love this Easter
Egg the way John held Dany after he
killed her is the same way he held his
co-star turned real-life wife Rose
Leslie when she died in his arms and as
for Emilia Clarke's Big Game of Thrones
regret she really wishes she stole
something from the set really hoping
because everyone else was like yeah we
took stuff
[Music]